Tim wasn't always perfect at his job. A couple years ago, not long after he got the job, he heard about these two gang members who had gotten into a scuffle at a club. It began when one of them jumped in front of the other in a line of people who were going to have their pictures taken.
蒂姆并不是一直都很胜任他的工作。几年前，在他刚得到这份工作不久后，他听说有两个帮派成员在一家夜店发生了冲突。起因是其中一个人在排队拍照时插到了另一个人的前面。
And they got into a big fight. And one of the guys got a black eye and was kind of messed up. And he was looking for the other guy to shoot him.
于是他们打了一场大架。其中一个人被打得眼眶发青，状况很惨。他当时正在寻找对方，想要开枪打死他。
Which is how Tim got involved. Tim, I have to say, has one of the greatest job titles ever. In a world where job titles often obscure what the hell a person does for a living, his is remarkably direct. He's an interrupter.
蒂姆就是这样卷入其中的。我不得不说，蒂姆拥有史上最棒的职位名称之一。在一个职位名称往往让人搞不清楚对方到底是干什么的世界里，他的头衔非常直观。他是一名“调停者”。
An interrupter means to interrupt violence, to intervene, or to mediate potential violent conflict.
“调停者”的意思是介入暴力事件，进行干预，或调解潜在的暴力冲突。
Years ago, Tim had been a gang member. He'd risen through the ranks, until finally he got to call the shots for his area on the West Side of Chicago. He became an interrupter when he got out of prison a few years back. So he gets these two guys together. They both knew him from the streets. They both respected him. But he was so inexperienced at being an interrupter that he held the meeting outside on a corner. And each guy brought friends.
多年前，蒂姆曾是一名帮派成员。他一步步晋升，最终能够在芝加哥西区独当一面。几年前出狱后，他成为了调停者。于是他把这两个人叫到了一起。他们都在街头认识他。他们也都尊重他。但他作为调停者还缺乏经验，所以他把会面地点选在外面街角。而且每个人都带了朋友过来。
What I messed up was, I didn't have control of the environment. I mean, they was instigating. Man, you let him hit you in your eye? You should do this to him. I lost control of the mediation. I was OK as long as I had them two there, right? But when everybody else started putting input in, and everybody starts saying, he ain't going to do nothing to me. And they start up in guns, I was the only one there without a gun. And I said, man, I don't have control.
我搞砸的地方在于，我没能掌控现场。我的意思是，他们在煽风点火。“伙计，你就让他把你眼睛打青了？你应该对他这样那样。”我失去了对调解过程的控制。只要只有他们两个人在，我还能应付，对吧？但当其他人也开始插嘴，每个人都开始说“他才不敢对我做什么”时，他们开始掏枪，而我是现场唯一没带枪的人。我说：“伙计们，我控制不了局面。”
They talking, and they was just about to pull it. Man, you should shoot him, man. And I was like, man, nah, don't shoot him. Man, don't shoot him. Please don't shoot that gun. And they were like, man, I ain't scared of you. I got a gun. You ain't the only one got no gun. And I was like, I ain't got nothin'. And so I was like, hey listen. Let's just get in our cars. Get in your car, get in your car. Man, get in your car. Man, the police are going to come. Get in your car. They finally got in their cars, and they pulled off. I said, this mediation ain't going right.
他们边说边准备掏枪。有人说：“伙计，你应该开枪射他。”我说：“不，伙计，别开枪。别开枪。求你们别开枪。”他们说：“伙计，我才不怕你。我有枪。不是只有你有枪。”我当时说：“我什么都没有。”所以我说：“嘿，听着，我们各自上车吧。上车，上车。伙计，快上车。警察要来了。上车。”他们终于上了车，开车离开了。我说：“这次调解进行得一点都不顺利。”
And so about two days later, I called these same two individuals. But this time, I had them meet me at the office, individually, one-on-one. And I explained to them, man, listen, man. You don't need to make these decisions that you're making, man. You're doing well out here in the streets. You're not starving. But if you make these decisions that you're going to make, you're going to bring a lot of heat on yourself. You don't want to hurt dude, he don't want to hurt you. Y'all was both drunk that night at that party. Ain't nobody dead. You got a black eye. People get black eyes when they get into fights. But you still can salvage this, man. And he listened. He had cooled off for a while. A couple of days had passed, he cooled off.
大约两天后，我又叫了这两个人。但这次，我让他们单独来办公室，一对一地谈。我向他们解释说：“伙计，听着。你没必要做出你们现在想做的决定。你们在街头混得不错。并没有挨饿。但如果你们做出那些决定，会给自己招来大麻烦。你不想伤害他，他也不想伤害你。那天晚上聚会时你们都喝多了。又没人死。只是眼眶青了。人打架总会挂彩的。但这事还是可以挽回的。”他听进去了。他冷静了一段时间。过了几天，他的气消了。
And I had already talked to the other guy. And he said, man, I don't got no problem talking to him. He the one that want to act like he want to-- we had to fight last night. He lost. What he want to do? He want to kill me now. And I ain't scared of him. I mean, if he trying to kill me, I'm trying to kill him.
我已经和另一个人谈过了。他说：“伙计，我没问题，可以和他谈。是他自己在那装模作样——我们昨晚打了一架。他输了。他想干嘛？他现在想杀我。我才不怕他。我是说，如果他想杀我，我也想杀他。”
So we got to the table, and we talked. And we squashed it. Because they really both didn't want to hurt each other. They knew each other from school and everything, but their pride was in the way. Their reputation was in the way.
于是我们坐下来谈了谈。我们平息了这件事。因为他们其实都不想伤害对方。他们从学校起就认识，但自尊心在作祟。名声在作祟。
What do you think they go back and tell their friends about why the fight's over? What do they say?
你觉得他们回去后会怎么跟朋友解释战斗结束的原因？他们怎么说？
That's what I mean about keep their reputation and their face value. They go back and say, man, I let it go, because Tim, man, you know? You know Tim stand for peace now, man. So he caught up with me, man. So I told him I'd do it for him. I gave dude a pass. And the other dude will tell his crew, I gave dude a pass for Tim, man. And so that's what they do.
这就是我所说的维护面子。他们回去会说：“伙计，我放过他了，因为蒂姆，你知道吧？你知道蒂姆现在主张和平。他来找我了，所以我卖他一个面子。我饶了那个家伙。”另一个人也会对他的团伙说：“我给蒂姆面子，放过那小子。”他们就是这样做的。
It's a favor to you.
这是卖你一个人情。
Yeah. They just give me some favors some time. And I stand on what I say. I'm not here to arrest you. I'm not here to talk about nothing. We're not there to put them in jail for whatever they're doing. We don't want to know nothing about your criminal activities, how you get money, how you making your money. Our component is totally to stop you from shooting each other.
是的。他们有时会卖我人情。而且我言出必行。我不是来抓你们的。我不是来谈别的什么的。我们到那里不是为了因为他们做的任何事就把他们关进监狱。我们不想了解你们的犯罪活动，不想知道你们如何搞钱。我们的核心目标仅仅是阻止你们互相开枪。
I met Tim through one of the contributors to our radio show, Alex Kotlowitz. He'd written about Tim and some other interrupters for The New York Times Magazine . Tim works for a group called CeaseFire, which this year has stepped in to mediate 78 potential shootings in Chicago. Tim's in his 40s. When he was in prison, he found God. When we came out, he was ordained as a minister, like his dad, actually, who has a church on the West Side. And though Tim loves the work he does now, he understands how hard it is for the guys he talks to not to take revenge. He's been tested too. Not long ago, he was in his car. He'd just dropped his son off.
我通过我们广播节目的撰稿人亚历克斯·科特洛维茨认识了蒂姆。他曾为《纽约时报杂志》写过关于蒂姆和其他调停者的文章。蒂姆为“停火”组织工作，该组织今年已介入调解了芝加哥78起潜在的枪击事件。蒂姆40多岁了。在监狱时，他找到了信仰。出狱后，他像他父亲一样成为了一名牧师，他父亲在西区有一座教堂。尽管蒂姆热爱他现在的工作，但他明白他所交谈的人要放弃复仇是多么困难。他也曾受到过考验。不久前，他正开着车，刚送完他儿子。
I was riding down Pulaski, and I was behind this young man and a woman in a car. He had to be doing like 20 miles an hour on a busy street. And he was swerving, just like listening to his music, bouncing up and down. I was kind of tired, and I wanted to get past him. And he wouldn't let me pass. Purposely, he wouldn't let me pass.
我开在普拉斯基路上，跟在一个年轻男子和一个女人开的车后面。他在繁忙的街道上大概只开20英里每小时。他还在左摇右晃，听着音乐，车身上下起伏。我当时有点累，想超车过去。但他不让我超车。他是故意不让我超。
He was like cutting you off when you try to go around?
你是说当你试图超车时他挡着你？
Yeah. So I caught myself going try to get past him, and he hit his brakes real hard and made me almost run into the back of his car. And when he jumped out, he started cussing me. MF, get away from my-- don't be riding so close to my car. I'll beat your woo, woo, woo. And I said, hey man, I just want to get past. He said, F you. Say something else and I'll slap you. And I was like, slap who? And he said, I'll slap you. Say something else. And I wanted to whoop him. I believe in my heart I could whoop this guy. I could take him. And I looked at him, I said, man, it's not that serious, man. We ain't got to go there. And he said, man, shut up.
是的。所以我再次尝试超车，他猛踩刹车，差点让我撞上他的车尾。他跳下车，开始骂我。“混蛋，离我的车远点……别靠我的车这么近。我会打得你满地找牙。”我说：“嘿，兄弟，我只是想超车。”他说：“去你的。再多说一句我就扇你。”我说：“扇谁？”他说：“我就扇你。再多说一句。”我当时很想揍他。我内心深信我能打赢这个家伙。我能搞定他。我看着他说：“兄弟，没必要这样，太严重了。我们没必要闹成这样。”他说：“闭嘴。”
I said, shut up? I said, all right, man. I just looked at him, and he looked at me. And he seen that he had punked me, so he walked away. And then he jumped in the car, and he called me a B. And then he got in his car and pulled off. And I stayed there and just sit for a minute. And tears started welling up in my eyes, and I was thinking about going on the block and getting a couple of guys. I know the car and stuff. I wanted to go and ride back around his neighborhood and see could I find him.
我说：“闭嘴？”我说：“好吧，伙计。”我只是看着他，他也看着我。他发现他已经吓住我了，就走开了。然后他跳进车里，骂我是个混蛋。他开着车离开了。我呆在原地坐了一会儿。泪水在眼眶里打转，我当时想回街区叫几个人来。我知道他的车和情况。我想开回去绕着他的街区找他。
And I was riding that way, and I'm riding that way. I said, man, I should kill this guy. He just disrespected me like that. Nobody never disrespected me like that. And then I pulled over, started to cry a little bit. And I said, nah, I'm going home.
我朝着那个方向开了一段路。我说：“伙计，我应该干掉这小子。他竟然那样羞辱我。从来没人敢那样羞辱我。”然后我把车靠边停下，开始哭了起来。我说：“不，我回家。”
Tim and the other interrupters are trying to do a kind of social engineering on the West Side, trying to change people's behavior on a mass scale, alter deeply ingrained social rules, make things better for everybody. And challenging as that is, it can be even more challenging to do that kind of retooling on yourself.
蒂姆和其他调停者正试图在西区进行一种“社会工程”，试图在大范围内改变人们的行为，改变根深蒂固的社会规则，让每个人的生活变得更好。尽管这很难，但对自己进行这种重塑可能更具挑战性。
It's hard to do a mediation on yourself. That's harder than doing a mediation for someone else. Because I was on the outside, I didn't have the emotions.
对自己进行调解很难。那比调解别人更难。因为我是局外人时，我可以不带情绪。
When you're doing it with other people?
当你和别人一起调解时？
When I'm doing it with other people, when they be mad. I had emotions that flared up in my throat. It was all up over me, it was everywhere. And I didn't know how to deal with it.
当我处理别人的事情时，哪怕他们很愤怒。我当时的情绪涌上喉咙。那种感觉笼罩着我，无处不在。而我不知道该如何处理它。
And that brings us to today's program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, we have several stories of people who are trying to social engineer their own lives. Act One, we have guys who remake their lives in this way that I think very few of us would ever dare. In Act Two, a parent tries to teach a kid a simple lesson, but does it in a way that he regrets for decades later. In Act Three, a mom understands that sticks and stones will, in fact, break your bones, but is not so clear if names will ever hurt her kid. Stay with us.
这把我们带到了今天的节目。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在节目中，我们有几个关于人们试图对自己进行“社会工程”的故事。第一幕，我们有几个人以一种我觉得很少有人敢尝试的方式重塑了自己的生活。第二幕，一位家长试图教孩子一个简单的道理，却用了让他几十年后都感到后悔的方式。第三幕，一位母亲明白“棍棒和石头固然会打断骨头”，但不确定刻薄的话语是否会伤害她的孩子。请继续收听。
Act One, Choosers, Not Beggars. Gregory Deloatch and Daniel Canada met in a bookstore, and they've had the kind of long-standing friendship where, at the center of things for the last 20 years, they've had a shared goal: to write something great. But all the normal stuff got in the way of that goal, marriages, jobs. And the dream to write something great became a lower priority, something more like a hobby. When Gregory was in his 20s, he write a sci-fi novel. And in their 30s, Gregory and Daniel co-wrote a big historical novel set in ancient Babylon and a second novel together called The Noise . None of these books were published.
第一幕，“选择者，而非乞讨者”。格雷戈里·德洛奇和丹尼尔·加拿大在一家书店相识，他们维持了20年的深厚友谊，核心目标只有一个：写出伟大的作品。但所有正常生活中的琐事都阻碍了这一目标，比如婚姻、工作。写出伟大作品的梦想被降级，更像是一种爱好。格雷戈里20多岁时写过一部科幻小说。30多岁时，格雷戈里和丹尼尔合著了一部以古巴比伦为背景的大型历史小说，以及第二部合著小说《噪音》。这些书都没有出版。
And it wasn't until their 40s that things really started to change, and they got serious about their writing. And they did this by re-engineering their lives in a pretty unusual way. Lu Olkowski explains.
直到40多岁，情况才真正开始改变，他们开始认真对待写作。他们通过一种非常不寻常的方式重新规划了自己的生活。卢·奥尔科夫斯基为您报道。
It wasn't that Gregory and Daniel decided to become homeless so they'd finally get enough free time to write. They slid into homelessness gradually. Gregory was making good money as a computer tech for a Wall Street firm, but he was drinking way too much, and finally his wife walked out. He found himself living alone in an apartment in New Jersey. His best friend, Daniel, meanwhile, was between jobs and divorced.
并不是格雷戈里和丹尼尔决定变得无家可归，好让自己有足够的时间去写作。他们是逐渐陷入这种状态的。格雷戈里曾在一家华尔街公司担任计算机技术员，收入不错，但他喝得太多了，最终妻子离他而去。他独自住在新泽西州的一间公寓里。与此同时，他最好的朋友丹尼尔正处于失业和离婚的状态。
So Gregory offered his couch to Daniel, and for a long while, things were all right. Daniel would write some during the day. Gregory worked nights, until Gregory lost his job. And he'd never been unemployed before, not really, not like Daniel. He began missing rent payments and couldn't see a way to catch up, and he was freaking out. And at this point, he could have gotten another job, or gone to his family for money. But he did nothing. And then it was the day before they were going to get evicted. Here's Gregory.
于是格雷戈里让丹尼尔睡在他的沙发上，很长一段时间里，一切都还好。丹尼尔白天会写点东西。格雷戈里上夜班，直到他丢了工作。他以前从未真正失业过，不像丹尼尔。他开始付不起房租，看不到补救的办法，他快崩溃了。此时，他本可以找另一份工作，或者向家人求助。但他什么也没做。接着，离他们被驱逐只有一天了。听听格雷戈里的叙述。
I'm like, dude, we're about to hit the street. And mister cool as a cucumber here was just relaxed. He wasn't stressed about anything.
我说：“伙计，我们要流落街头了。”而这位冷静得像冰块一样的家伙却很放松。他一点也不紧张。
Daniel felt this way because he'd lived on the streets before.
丹尼尔之所以有这种感觉，是因为他以前露宿过街头。
And then he said, that's survivable. For the first time, it didn't really key in, because you don't think you can survive the streets. When someone says, being homeless, I don't think you can do it. I'm like saying to him, where do you use the bathroom?
他说：“那是可以生存下来的。”起初我没反应过来，因为你认为自己无法在街头生存。当有人说“变得无家可归”时，我觉得你不可能做到。我问他：“你在哪里上厕所？”
I remember that.
我记得那个。
Where do you take a shower? How do you get clean? Where do you get new clothes? I had a million questions, and he carefully answered every last one of them. This is what you do. This is what you'll do. This is what you'll do. So that when the last day came and just before the county sheriffs came to lock me out, we left. I grabbed what clothes I had on my back and a bag, and we headed to the Port Authority.
“你到哪儿洗澡？怎么保持清洁？到哪儿找新衣服？”我有一百万个问题，他小心翼翼地回答了每一个。这是你应该做的，那是你应该做的，以此类推。所以当最后一天到来，就在县警上门锁门前，我们离开了。我抓起背上的衣服和一个包，我们前往港务局车站。
Up until he lost his apartment, the Port Authority bus station in New York was just a transfer station on Gregory's route to and from work. But on that night in May 2006, it became shelter. A few nights sleeping in the Port Authority turned into weeks. But somehow, because they had each other, being homeless in New York City didn't seem as daunting as it might have. It was kind of an adventure. Gregory and Daniel treated it like a game, spending the last of Gregory's money on going to the movies and bars. They wanted to shed the baggage and stress of their old lives, no full-time jobs, no wives, no hassle. They wanted to live a little, reevaluate things.
在失去公寓之前，纽约的港务局巴士站只是格雷戈里上下班途中的中转站。但那一晚，2006年5月，它成了避难所。在港务局睡了几晚后变成了几周。但不知何故，因为他们拥有彼此，在纽约市流落街头并没有想象中那么可怕。这算是一种冒险。格雷戈里和丹尼尔把它当成一场游戏，把格雷戈里剩下的钱花在看电影和去酒吧上。他们想甩掉旧生活的包袱和压力，没有全职工作，没有妻子，没有麻烦。他们想享受生活，重新评估一切。
And it was during this time that Gregory and Daniel forged a plan, an experiment. They'd use homelessness to finally get serious about their writing. Here's Daniel.
正是在这段时间里，格雷戈里和丹尼尔制定了一个计划，一个实验。他们将利用无家可归来终于认真地投入写作。听听丹尼尔怎么说。
We wanted to eliminate the distraction and maximize the time that we spend in pursuing this. We are devoting all our energy to it. This is our life. This is our career. This is our nine-to-five. Our particular talent is poetry, open mic, spoken word.
我们想消除干扰，最大限度地利用时间来追求这个目标。我们把所有精力都投入其中。这就是我们的生活。这是我们的事业。这是我们的朝九晚五。我们的特长是诗歌、公开麦、口语诗。
And so Gregory and Daniel, without jobs, without homes, got to work. They had a routine. If they were writing something together, like their novel or screenplay, they'd work at the New York Public Library. Otherwise, they'd split up during the day, but meet up every morning for breakfast and every night before bed, just to check in on one another. They'd stay on each other to be productive. Daniel is more likely to wander the city, hoping to get an idea for a poem. Gregory has a laptop, so he spends most days at a Midtown Starbucks, where uses free wifi to write his blog.
于是格雷戈里和丹尼尔，没有工作，没有家，开始行动了。他们有自己的规律。如果他们一起写东西，比如小说或剧本，他们就在纽约公共图书馆工作。否则，他们白天分开行动，但每天早上吃早餐时和晚上睡觉前都会碰面，只是为了确认彼此的状态。他们互相监督，保证产出。丹尼尔更倾向于在城市里漫步，希望能为诗歌寻找灵感。格雷戈里有一台笔记本电脑，所以他大部分时间都在曼哈顿中城的星巴克，利用免费的wifi写博客。
And a month after they went on the streets, they hit the poetry circuit. Two months in, their schedule was packed enough to include three different readings a week. Saturday's at Stark on West 43rd Street, Sundays at Smith's Bar in Times Square or at ABC No Rio on the Lower East Side, Mondays downtown at the Nightingale. On stage, Gregory became Hobo Bob, Daniel was Obsidian. They were the homeless poets. That was their schtick on the poetry circuit.
在流落街头一个月后，他们进入了诗歌圈。两个月后，他们的日程排满了，每周包括三场不同的朗诵会。周六在西43街的Stark，周日在时代广场的Smith's酒吧或下东区的ABC No Rio，周一在市中心的Nightingale。在舞台上，格雷戈里变成了“流浪汉鲍勃”，丹尼尔是“黑曜石”。他们是“无家可归的诗人”。那是他们在诗歌圈的卖点。
Next up, please welcome our wonderful homeless poet, Hobo Bob.
接下来，请欢迎我们出色的无家可归诗人，流浪汉鲍勃。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And this is where I first encountered them, over a year ago in 2007. It was Obsidian who knew the places they could perform, and Obsidian does most of the MCing when they're on stage together. He's the outgoing one, the one who works the room at intermission. Gregory's more thoughtful, introspective. And at the beginning it was Obsidian, you know, Daniel, who showed Gregory how to live on the street, how to keep warm on a cool night by stuffing their clothes with crumpled up newspaper, where there was a storefront in Midtown with planters that hid them from view, so they could sleep without anyone bugging them. Also how to stock up on free necessities. Here's Daniel.
这是我一年多前，也就是2007年第一次遇到他们的地方。是黑曜石知道他们可以表演的地方，而且当他们一起上台时，大部分主持人工作都是黑曜石做的。他是那个外向的人，中场休息时会在场子里活跃气氛。格雷戈里更沉思、内省。起初是黑曜石，也就是丹尼尔，向格雷戈里展示了如何在街头生活，如何通过在衣服里塞满揉皱的报纸在凉爽的夜晚保持温暖，哪里有曼哈顿中城的店面有花槽能遮挡视线，让他们可以睡觉而没人打扰。还有如何储备免费的生活必需品。听听丹尼尔怎么说。
Go into McDonald's, and get you a handful of them. And put them in your bag or your pocket when you need napkins.
走进麦当劳，抓一把餐巾纸。当你需要餐巾纸时，把它们放在包里或口袋里。
Why do you need so many napkins?
为什么你需要那么多餐巾纸？
They're amazing.
它们太神奇了。
They do everything.
它们无所不能。
You'll find so many uses of just a napkin.
你会发现餐巾纸有很多用途。
If you use a public toilet and can't shut the door you just-- you know some of those stalls, they kind of like swing like swinging doors. The locks are broken, so you need to use it, and the door keeps running open. So you take a couple of napkins, and you just wedge them right in the door.
如果你使用公共厕所，门关不上，你知道有些隔间是那种像旋转门一样的。锁坏了，你需要用它，但门总弹开。所以你拿几张餐巾纸，直接塞进门缝里。
Daniel also taught Gregory the importance of socks.
丹尼尔还教格雷戈里袜子有多重要。
Socks. Your feet go first. When you're in the street, you keep your feet in your shoe all the time. It doesn't get any air. And once it smells like hell like that, it contaminates your shoe. Now your shoe stinks. You could hold the bank up with them. You notice that if you smell an odor around a homeless person, the odor you're smelling is the feet. So you always got to constantly make sure you have a pair of socks on your feet, a pair in the bag.
袜子。你的脚最先出问题。当你流落街头，你一直穿着鞋。脚部没有空气流通。一旦像那样臭气熏天，它就会污染你的鞋子。现在你的鞋子也臭了。你可以穿着它们去抢银行。你会注意到，如果你闻到无家可归者身上的味道，你闻到的是脚臭味。所以你必须时刻确保脚上有双袜子，包里还要有一双。
They get fresh socks at the Bowery Mission, which also provides new clothes and showers for the homeless. Every Tuesday, Gregory and Daniel go there, throw away the old clothes they've been wearing for a week, and each gets a whole new outfit. It matters to them that they look good. They're clean-shaven with proper haircuts, no grime under their nails, dark chinos, and button-down shirts. In other words, they pass. You wouldn't know they were homeless unless they told you.
他们从Bowery慈善机构获得新鲜袜子，那里也为无家可归者提供新衣服和淋浴。每个周二，格雷戈里和丹尼尔都会去那里，扔掉穿了一周的旧衣服，每人领一套全新的衣服。他们很在意自己的仪表。他们刮得干干净净，理着整齐的短发，指甲缝里没有污垢，穿着深色休闲裤和扣领衬衫。换句话说，他们能“混过去”。除非他们自己说，否则你不会知道他们是无家可归者。
Which is not true for a lot of the homeless people they see around town, guys they've privately nicknamed Adolph, Scurvy, Coat, Buzzard, Frank 'n Beans, the Marlboro Man. They classify the bags homeless people carry from large to small into class A, B, C, or D Starfleet. Gregory has a solid class D Star Cruiser, a sensible black wheelie suitcase with a matching computer bag. The longer you're on the street, the bigger your starship tends to get, and the class A Star Destroyer is one of those giant canvas postal carts, overflowing with stuff, with more stuff tied to the sides and on poles.
但他们在城里看到的许多其他无家可归者并非如此，比如他们私下戏称为“阿道夫”、“坏血病”、“大衣”、“秃鹫”、“法兰克和豆子”、“万宝路男人”的那些人。他们根据无家可归者携带的包的大小将其分为A、B、C或D级星际舰队。格雷戈里有一个稳固的D级星际巡洋舰，一个配套的黑色拉杆箱和电脑包。你在街头待的时间越长，你的星舰往往就越大，所谓的“A级歼星舰”就是那种巨大的邮政帆布手推车，塞满了杂物，还有更多东西绑在侧面和杆子上。
Well, there's three types of homeless people. There's homeless people who are just homeless, and they're trying to make the best they can. And some of them, you can't even tell they're homelessness unless you follow them around. They change their clothes. They upkeep themselves. You see them in the library reading a book or something. That's one. That's us. Then there's a Skeksis, where they'll be very dirty.
无家可归者有三种类型。第一种是仅仅无家可归的人，他们尽力过好生活。有些人甚至看不出他们无家可归，除非你跟着他们。他们换衣服，保持整洁。你在图书馆看到他们读书什么的。那就是第一种。我们就是这样。然后是“斯克西斯”，他们会非常脏。
Dressed in all kinds of clothes, sometimes many layers and layers of clothes.
穿着各种各样的衣服，有时甚至穿好几层。
They'll wear heavy coats in the wintertime-- I'm sorry, in the summertime. You don't want to smell them when they open up those coats. And they even talk differently. Their language has devolved. They don't speak in words anymore. They speak more in sounds, more like [SCREECHING SOUNDS].
夏天的时候也会穿厚大衣。我不建议你在他们打开大衣时闻那味道。他们说话的方式也不一样。他们的语言退化了。他们不再用词汇交流。他们更多是用声音，听起来像[尖叫声]。
[SCREECHING SOUNDS]. Honest to God.
[尖叫声]。向上帝发誓。
But that's Skeksis. He's talking Skeksis.
但他那是斯克西斯。他在说斯克西斯语。
He's on his way.
他正在变成那样。
He's talking Skeksis.
他在说斯克西斯语。
And then there's the last one, recently classified.
还有最后一种，最近分类的。
Skels.
“斯克尔”（Skels）。
Skels. Or Skelsis.
斯克尔。或者“斯克尔西斯”。
Skelsis. Skelsi is the living dead. It's the undead. It's a person who, they're gone, mentally gone. And you'll just see them like sitting on the floor with their feet out maybe, and they're just really filthy. And they're just scratching themselves, and they're just talking to themselves loud. And they're just gone. That's it. That's the last level. That's called Skel. And Skell is the terminology that police use for homeless people. They call them Skells, which is short for skeletons. So whenever they go on the mocrophone, they say we have a Skell here. They're referring to a homeless person. They refer to all homeless people as Skells. They don't see a difference.
斯克尔西斯。斯克尔西斯就是行尸走肉。是亡灵。是一个人，他们完了，精神上完了。你会看到他们坐在地上，双脚伸出来，非常肮脏。他们只是在抓挠自己，大声自言自语。他们完了。就是这样。那是最后一个阶段。这叫“斯克尔”。而“斯克尔”是警察对无家可归者的术语。他们称之为“Skells”，是“骷髅”（Skeletons）的缩写。所以每当他们用麦克风说话时，就会说“这有个斯克尔”。他们指的是无家可归者。他们把所有无家可归者都称为斯克尔。他们看不出区别。
Maybe the most remarkable thing about Gregory and Daniel is how upbeat they were about all this. It's hard to imagine being so happy living on the street. But when I first met them a year ago, they'd been on the street for a year already, and they were almost always like this. Though Gregory said there was one thing he definitely did not like about living on the street.
关于格雷戈里和丹尼尔，最引人注目的也许是他们对这一切表现得多么乐观。很难想象住在街上还能这么快乐。但当我一年前第一次见到他们时，他们已经在街上住了一年了，而且他们几乎总是这样。尽管格雷戈里说有一件事他绝对不喜欢露宿街头。
No one told me that being homeless meant celibacy. That was the biggest thing. I didn't think about it. I didn't think about it at all. I'm like, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. But you know what? Obsidian picked up some. It's the magic of Obsidian. Yeah. He had two girlfriends since he was homeless. Two. It's the Obsidian suave, suave, sua-vay, charisma. You know, he's handsome. He's young. He's got it going on. He's not afraid to say it. But I'm more rugged looking, more pie-faced, more out of shape. The two of us standing together, women are going to gravitate to him, and I'm going to be the one going to get the drinks.
没人告诉我流落街头意味着禁欲。那是最大的一件事。我完全没想过。我完全没考虑过。[听不清]。但你知道吗？黑曜石还是搞到了一些。这就是黑曜石的魔力。是的。他从流落街头开始就有两个女朋友了。两个。那是黑曜石的魅力，优雅，有魅力。你知道，他长得帅。他年轻。他有一套。他敢于表达。但我长得更粗犷，脸圆圆的，身材走形。我们俩站在一起，女人肯定会被他吸引，而我就是那个去买饮料的人。
They squeaked by with a little money from occasional odd jobs. Gregory wrote reviews of porno films. He didn't get paid, but he got to keep the DVDs, which he sold for $2 apiece to video stores. Obsidian would take a day here and there doing small construction jobs. And Gregory's mom sent him $100 every month. And they started to make some money from poetry. When they were featured together at the East Orange Public Library in New Jersey, they got $100 each. As for food, they're eating well, gaining weight even.
他们靠偶尔打零工赚的那点钱勉强度日。格雷戈里写过色情电影影评。他没拿到钱，但可以留下DVD，他以每张2美元的价格卖给录像店。黑曜石则偶尔做点小型建筑工作。格雷戈里的妈妈每个月寄给他100美元。他们开始通过诗歌赚到钱。当他们一起在新泽西州的东奥兰治公共图书馆演出时，每人得到了100美元。至于食物，他们吃得很好，体重甚至增加了。
There's no such thing as a hungry homeless person.
根本没有所谓的饥饿的无家可归者。
In this city?
在这个城市？
You can't be hungry.
你不可能饿肚子。
That's a joke.
那是笑话。
Too many places to eat.
太多地方可以吃了。
Anyone that has a sign that says, I'm hungry and haven't eaten in three days--
任何举着牌子说“我饿了，三天没吃饭”的人——
That's a joke.
那是个笑话。
--is lying.
——是在撒谎。
It's a scam.
那是骗局。
这是骗局。
The city is littered with soup kitchens, littered. And the quality of the food is good. They have good quality food, fresh vegetables. Incredible. It's the churches. Most of them are the churches. If it wasn't for the churches, the homeless people would starve to death.
城市里到处都是施粥处。食物质量很好。他们有高质量的食物，新鲜蔬菜。令人难以置信。多亏了教堂。如果不是因为教堂，无家可归者早就饿死了。
Federal programs suck.
联邦计划烂透了。
Suck. Even the quality of the food sucks at the federal program. And they give you so little bit of it. The churches, however, on the other hand, the people go out of their way to cook good food for you, serve you.
烂透了。联邦计划里的食物质量也很差。而且他们给的份量很少。另一方面，教堂的人竭尽全力为你烹饪美食，招待你。
They want you there. They treat you differently.
他们希望你在那里。他们对待你的方式不同。
They perform music for you.
他们为你演奏音乐。
Breakfast there is wonderful. It's always something great.
那里的早餐太棒了。总是很棒的东西。
Corn beef hash, beef stew.
咸牛肉饼，牛肉炖菜。
Chicken, fish, salmon, fresh salmon, fresh whitefish. Oh man, lamb, steak, beef.
鸡肉，鱼，鲑鱼，新鲜鲑鱼，新鲜白鲑。哦天哪，羊肉，牛排，牛肉。
They let you go around and get more.
他们让你绕过去再拿一份。
Go around as many times as you want. Knock yourself out.
你想绕多少次都行。随便吃。
They give you a bag of food on the way out.
他们离开时还会给你一袋食物。
Are you the person this food is meant for? You could have made a living, you're competent.
你是这些食物的目标受众吗？你本可以谋生，你有能力。
Is it meant for us? I mean, do all homeless people have to be disabled? Do all homeless people have to be crazy?
它是为我们准备的吗？我是说，所有的无家可归者都必须残疾吗？所有的无家可归者都必须是疯子吗？
It's for the hungry. There are people who have jobs that eat there too.
它是为饥饿的人准备的。也有有工作的人在那里吃饭。
But do you think people would want to be donating to you?
但你觉得人们会愿意给你们捐款吗？
We're donating to these guys' experiment? Would they donate if they knew it was coming to us? No, no.
我们在资助这些人的实验？如果他们知道这些钱是给我们的，他们会捐吗？不会，不会。
Though Gregory and Daniel are the rare homeless people who got into homelessness as a lifestyle choice, there's not such a clear line dividing them from some of the more hardcore cases at the soup kitchens. After all, it was alcohol that got Gregory fired from his last job and brought him to the point that homelessness became an option.
尽管格雷戈里和丹尼尔是极少数把流落街头当作生活方式选择的无家可归者，但他们与施粥处里一些更严重的情况之间并没有那么明确的界限。毕竟，是酒精导致格雷戈里丢掉了最后一份工作，并把他推向了不得不考虑流落街头的境地。
I was making 60 grand a year, 60 grand not working hard. If I wanted to push it, I could push it to 70. They want you to do overtime in Wall Street. Wall Street judges you by overtime. So yeah, I was raking it in. I was spending it just as fast on alcohol. I was downing alcohol like nobody's business. I would get up around 8:00 at night, take a shower. Have a pint of Jack Daniels on me when I got into my car and drove to work. Finished that pint by the time I got out of Port Authority. Stop, get another pint, go into work.
我一年赚6万美元，赚得又不辛苦。如果我想拼一拼，可以推到7万。他们希望你在华尔街加班。华尔街以加班来评价你。所以是的，我赚得盆满钵满。我把钱花在酒精上，花得一样快。我简直像不要命一样喝酒。我晚上8点左右起床，洗个澡。当我开车去上班时，身上带一品脱杰克丹尼。等我走出港务局时，那品脱酒就喝完了。停下来，再买一品脱，再去上班。
Don't want to drink the pint, because I don't want to blast through it. Put the pint in the drawer, go to the Dakota Road House, and drink shots all night. Eight hours later, come back, grab my pint. Get off work, and go to another bar, Smith's, and drink all day until I got tired, shots.
我不想把那品脱酒喝光，因为我不想喝得太快。把酒瓶放在抽屉里，去达科塔路酒吧，整晚喝烈酒。八小时后，回来，拿上我的酒。下班后，去另一家酒吧Smith's，整天喝酒直到我累了，一直喝烈酒。
Counterintuitively, he does less drinking now that he's homeless. He doesn't have the money to keep up his rigorous Jack Daniels routine. And Gregory and Daniel don't beg. It's a rule. Begging is Skeksi. Here's Gregory.
反直觉的是，他现在流落街头喝得反而少了。他没有钱来维持他严格的杰克丹尼程序。而且格雷戈里和丹尼尔不乞讨。这是规则。乞讨是斯克西斯的行为。听听格雷戈里说。
Most benefit to me of being homeless is the fact that it kept me from drinking, kept me from smoking.
流落街头对我最大的好处就是它让我远离了酒精，远离了香烟。
And that's not the only self-improvement perk homelessness gave him.
而且这还不是流浪生活给他带来的唯一自我提升的福利。
Therapy, therapy. The state gives it to you. You must be nuts if you're on the street. So the state has--
治疗，治疗。政府会提供。如果你在街头，你一定疯了。所以政府有——
So you say I'm homeless, can I have therapy, and they'll just give it to you?
所以你说“我无家可归，能给我做心理治疗吗”，他们就会给你做？
You're homeless, we'll give you therapy.
你是无家可归者，我们就给你治疗。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
All of this is paid by Medicaid, which also pays for his eyeglasses and his prescriptions. Once he started treatment, Gregory learned that the voices he hears in his head sometimes, loud, insistent voices, which he assumed came from drinking so much, were signs that he's bipolar and schizophrenic. And now he gets meds to keep that under control, all free. So there were benefits to being on the street, including for their poetry.
所有这些都由医疗补助支付，这还支付了他的眼镜和处方药。一旦开始治疗，格雷戈里得知他脑子里有时听到的声音，那些响亮、强迫的声音，他原以为是因为喝太多酒引起的，其实是他患有双相情感障碍和精神分裂症的迹象。现在他靠药物来控制，全部免费。所以露宿街头确实有好处，包括对他们的诗歌创作。
After a few months, Gregory and Daniel decided to start their own open mic night called "The Times Square Shout Out" at one of Gregory's old drinking haunts on Eighth Avenue. They co-hosted, and it was popular enough that they started to dream of being discovered. A lot of their poetry has to do life on the streets or the lives they left behind. Here's Obsidian.
几个月后，格雷戈里和丹尼尔决定在格雷戈里以前喝酒的一个老窝点开始他们自己的公开麦之夜，叫“时代广场呐喊”。他们共同主持，而且人气很旺，以至于他们开始梦想被星探发现。他们的许多诗歌都与街头生活或他们留下的生活有关。听听黑曜石怎么说。
This one's entitled "Where's Daniel?" Of course, you know my real name is Daniel. Where's Daniel at? In alleyways and sleazy barbacks, on cheapened soup lines with hands in pockets against the wind. Where's Daniel at?
这一首题为“丹尼尔在哪里？”当然，你知道我的真名是丹尼尔。丹尼尔在哪里？在小巷和廉价的酒吧后台，在廉价的施粥队里，把手插在兜里抵御寒风。丹尼尔在哪里？
Daniel, Obsidian, comes on stage with his poetry on scraps of newspaper and napkins. But Gregory, Hobo Bob, is the one with the computer. And he comes onstage with all the poems printed out in crisp sheets, protected in plastic.
丹尼尔，黑曜石，带着写在碎报纸和餐巾纸上的诗歌上台。但格雷戈里，流浪汉鲍勃，是有电脑的那个人。他带着所有打印得整整齐齐、用塑料保护好的诗歌上台。
This one's, "I'm Hobo Bob." I'm Hobo Bob. And they call me that because I own nothing, insolvent, collateral-less, without liquidity. Me? Ha ha, I laugh. They say Bloomberg owns Gracie Mansion, but I don't see him out there when I'm sleeping on his lawn. I'm Hobo Bob.
这一首是“我是流浪汉鲍勃”。我是流浪汉鲍勃。他们这样叫我，因为我一无所有，无力偿债，没有抵押品，没有流动性。我？哈哈，我笑了。他们说布隆伯格拥有葛雷西大厦，但我没见过我在他草坪上睡觉时他在外面。我是流浪汉鲍勃。
Neither of these guys will be the next Poet Laureate, but at their readings, and other people's too, they really stood out. They were popular, and not just because they were homeless. A lot of the readers at these amateur open mics, frankly, are pretty boring. But Gregory and Daniel are natural performers who play to the crowd. And the crowds love them.
他们两个都不会成为下一位桂冠诗人，但在他们的朗诵会上，以及别人的朗诵会上，他们确实脱颖而出。他们很受欢迎，不仅仅因为他们无家可归。老实说，在这些业余公开麦上，很多朗诵者都挺无聊的。但格雷戈里和丹尼尔是天生的表演者，他们会带动观众。观众也很爱他们。
The first one's entitled "A Few of My Favorite Things."
第一首题为“我最喜爱的东西”。
[SINGING TO THE TUNE OF "MY FAVORITE THINGS" BY RICHARD RODGERS] Waking up achy and out in the open. Guard dogs are barking before words are spoken. Wrought iron benches that causes suffering--
[随着理查德·罗杰斯的“我最喜爱的东西”旋律演唱] 醒来时浑身酸痛，在户外。护卫犬在话语说出口前狂吠。那些造成痛苦的锻铁长凳——
These are a few of my favorite things.
这些是我最喜爱的东西。
Taking a shower with four dozen others. Moving around in a stench that could smother. Finding that you are the source of the stink.
和四十几个人一起淋浴。在能让人窒息的恶臭中走动。发现你自己就是恶臭的源头。
These are a few of my favorite things. When the bottle's dry--
这些是我最喜爱的东西。当酒瓶干了——
Then about a year after they hit the street, they suffered their first big setback. The bar where they hosted the shout-out got tired of it and canceled the show, and their dream of being discovered suddenly seemed a little less realistic. And being on the street was getting old. Here's Daniel.
在他们流落街头大约一年后，他们遭遇了第一次重大挫折。他们主持“呐喊”节目的酒吧厌倦了这一切，取消了演出，他们被发现的梦想突然显得不那么现实了。而且在街头生活也开始让人感到厌倦。听听丹尼尔怎么说。
You know what? It's getting to be tiring. At first it started off, it was kind of simple. But then, as you continue to be out there, it wears on you actually. It wears on you psychologically. It wears on you physically in various ways. So now, we're at the point where it's tiring, and we are working our way to get out of it. But now, the interesting thing about it is once you go into the streets, it's not so easy to extract yourself. It's easy to get in, but not easy to get out. It's like roach motel.
你知道吗？这变得很累人。起初它看起来很简单。但是，当你继续待在那里时，它确实会消耗你。它在心理上消耗你。它在身体上以各种方式消耗你。所以现在，我们到了厌倦的地步，我们正在努力走出去。但现在，有趣的是，一旦你进入街头，就很难把自己拔出来。进去容易，出来难。就像蟑螂旅馆。
And it was Daniel, Obsidian, the one with more experience on the streets, who took off. He bailed for his mom's place in South Carolina, leaving Gregory by himself. I caught up with Gregory then. This is August of last year. He looked spent and needed a haircut and fresh clothes.
结果是丹尼尔，黑曜石，那个街头经验更丰富的人，先离开了。他跑回了南卡罗来纳州的母亲家，留下了格雷戈里一个人。我在那时找到了格雷戈里。那是去年8月。他看起来筋疲力尽，需要剪头发和换干净衣服。
Yeah, I'm in Skek mode. Yeah, I'm in Skek mode.
是的，我处于斯克西斯模式。是的，我处于斯克西斯模式。
Skek mode, one step down the homeless ladder.
斯克西斯模式，流浪阶梯往下一级。
Oh man. It's been a rough one with Obsidian leaving. We never really had a chance to sit down and talk about it because I don't really talk about a lot of things. But he packed up and had to go. I can understand, it's a tough life. It's not easy. I could tell, as we were going along, he was complaining about every little thing. There was more and more discussion about sleeping in a bed. Oh man, crawling into a bed, there's nothing like it. You need your eight hours of sleep, and it has to be contiguous. It can't be broken sleep. You have no one waking you up. You know, da-da-da-da. OK, we know this. I mean, you're preaching to the choir here.
哦天哪。黑曜石离开后日子很难过。我们从来没有机会坐下来谈论这件事，因为我真的不谈论很多事情。但他收拾行李必须走了。我能理解，这是艰苦的生活。不容易。我能看出来，当我们一起走的时候，他在抱怨每一件小事。关于睡在床上的讨论越来越多。哦天哪，爬进一张床，没有什么能比得上它。你需要八小时的睡眠，而且必须是连续的。不能是断断续续的睡眠。没有人在你睡着时吵醒你。你知道，大大的OK，我们知道了。我是说，你是在对牛弹琴。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But yeah, he would go back and forth with that. And then he's like, my mother, she says she can get the internet for me, and she can do this for me, she could do that for me. So then plans were being drawn.
但是的，他会反复谈论那个。然后他说，我妈妈，她说她能给我弄到互联网，她能为我做这个，为我做那个。所以计划就开始制定了。
When Daniel had been around, everything seemed hopeful. They were a team, and somehow that made the difference. And when Daniel left, Gregory felt abandoned. He was hurt. And finally, in November of 2007, alone after a year and a half on the street, Gregory found permanent shelter at a halfway house in the East Village called the Bowery Resident's Committee with the help of one of his doctors. He got his own bunk. And now he wouldn't shut up about the comforts of a warm bed, about being able to look out the window at people trudging through the cold, while he watches the morning news and eats Cheerios.
当丹尼尔在的时候，一切似乎都充满了希望。他们是一个团队，不知何故，这产生了不同。而当丹尼尔离开时，格雷戈里感到被抛弃了。他很受伤。最终，在2007年11月，在街上漂泊了一年半后，格雷戈里在一位医生的帮助下，在东村一家名为Bowery居民委员会的半途之家中找到了永久居所。他有了自己的铺位。现在，他总是喋喋不休地谈论着温暖床铺的舒适，谈论着可以从窗户看着人们在寒风中吃力地行走，而他自己则看着早间新闻，吃着Cheerios麦片。
BRC has been around since 1971 and screens and monitors the people staying with them. There are rules to living there. Residents have to help with chores. There are regular community meetings to attend, mandated curfew, and regular drug and alcohol testing. Any violation of the rules risks getting kicked out, which seemed fine with Gregory, even welcome. And when Daniel got bored in South Carolina and moved back to New York, he started taking construction jobs, hoping to work much more regularly, so he could finally get off the street and into an SRO, a single room occupancy hotel.
BRC自1971年成立以来，一直对入住者进行筛选和监督。那里有居住规则。住户必须帮忙做家务。有定期的社区会议，规定的宵禁，以及定期的药物和酒精测试。违反任何规则都有被赶出去的风险，这在格雷戈里看来似乎还可以，甚至受欢迎。当丹尼尔在南卡罗来纳州感到无聊并搬回纽约时，他开始做建筑工作，希望能更稳定地工作，这样他最终也能离开街道，住进SRO（单人房住宿酒店）。
And so Gregory and Daniel's experiment to use homelessness as a way to dedicate more time to their poetry is over. And just last week, I asked Daniel and Gregory if it worked. Here's Daniel.
所以格雷戈里和丹尼尔利用无家可归作为投入诗歌创作时间的实验结束了。就在上周，我问丹尼尔和格雷戈里这是否奏效。听听丹尼尔怎么说。
Not the way we wanted it to. Like I said at the beginning, we wanted to take this open mic venue beyond Russell Simmons or Def Poetry Jam.
不像我们想要的那样。就像我开头说的，我们想把这个公开麦场所超越罗素·西蒙斯或 Def Poetry Jam。
We thought that by now we'd be sought by television and driving around in fancy cars, be millionaires. That was success for us. We didn't know better. You're going to make a living off of being a poet? I don't think so. We were like, well hey, hard smack of reality there, you know?
我们以为到现在我们会被电视台追捧，开着豪华轿车，成为百万富翁。那对我们来说就是成功。我们没见识。你要靠写诗谋生？我不觉得。我们当时就像，嘿，现实的沉重一击，你知道吧？
Being homeless, was it worth it?
流落街头，值得吗？
That's a good question. Being homeless, was it worth it? Being homeless, was it worth it? Being homeless, I would say, making the choice to spend that time doing something, which is writing poetry and getting into the poetry circuit, that was definitely worth the choice. We got, I guess you can say, the joy of being poets. Read our poetry in front of a lot of people, be heard by a lot of people, that's an adrenaline rush. And we did so well that the experiment worked.
这是个好问题。流落街头，值得吗？流落街头，值得吗？关于流落街头，我会说，做出选择花费那些时间去做一件事，那就是写诗并进入诗歌圈，那绝对是值得的选择。我们得到了，我想你可以说是，作为诗人的快乐。在很多人面前朗读我们的诗歌，被很多人听到，那是一种肾上腺素的冲动。我们做得很好，实验成功了。
If you look back to three years ago, when you were making money, you had a real job making real money, 70 grand, and you have skills. Does it surprise you that now, three years later, you are dependent on other people to help you find housing and a job, things that you did for 40 years on your own?
如果你回顾三年前，那时候你在赚钱，有一份真正的工作赚着真正的钱，7万块，而且你有技能。现在，三年后，你依赖别人来帮你找住处和工作，这些你原本靠自己做了40年的事情，这让你惊讶吗？
Three years ago, looking in, I would never believe that I would be in social services or have a committee looking for an apartment for me, because I could do all that myself. But I wasn't happy. I wasn't genuinely happy. I was going through the motions of working a job, and I didn't feel fulfilled. I'm homeless, I'm in the circuit. I'm writing poetry. This is a different life. But, to me, it's a far better life than going back to working in computers and networking and all that. I mean, I wouldn't like to go back to that lifestyle. And if it takes going through social services and all that to avoid that lifestyle, I would choose no other way.
三年前，回顾来看，我永远不会相信自己会依赖社会服务，或者有一个委员会帮我找公寓，因为我能自己做所有这些。但我当时不快乐。我不是真的快乐。我只是在机械地做着一份工作，我感到没有成就感。我现在无家可归，我在诗歌圈。我在写诗。这是一种不同的生活。但是，对我来说，这远比回到做电脑、做网络那些工作要好得多。我是说，我不想回到那种生活方式。如果通过社会服务能避免那种生活方式，我不会选择其他路。
But in the last few months, something else has changed for Gregory. Having Daniel back from South Carolina, seeing Daniel drink and stay out late was a catalyst, he says. It made him question whether he should stick with a life of curfews and breathalyzers and drug testing. And two weeks ago, talking to Gregory, I learned that hanging out with Daniel has had an effect. He started drinking secretly, and planning to drink a lot more.
但在过去几个月里，格雷戈里身上发生了另一件事。他说，黑曜石从南卡罗来纳州回来，看到黑曜石喝酒且熬夜是一个导火索。这让他质疑自己是否应该坚持那种有宵禁、呼吸酒精测试和药物测试的生活。两周前，和格雷戈里交谈时，我得知和丹尼尔混在一起产生了影响。他开始偷偷喝酒，并计划喝得更多。
Oh, I know I'm going to slip back into my old habits. That's a given. That's what I'm waiting for. That's the party after the war. No, I'm totally waiting for that day when I can close the door and lock it. And I don't have anyone saying, come here for a minute, I want you to blow into this tube. And then I'm going to go outside, and I'm going to buy a nice quart size-- or family size. I'm going to get the family size, which is a little bit bigger, of Jack Daniels and sneak it upstairs. And just pound on that thing for hours and hours and hours and hours.
哦，我知道我会滑回老习惯。这是必然的。我正在等那个。那是战争后的派对。不，我完全在等待那一天，那时我可以关上门并锁上。没有人对我说：“过来一会儿，我要你对着这根管子吹气。”然后我要走出去，买一夸脱大小——或者家庭装。我要买家庭装，它比平时大一点，杰克丹尼，把它偷偷带上楼。然后在那东西上痛饮数小时，数小时，数小时，数小时。
I'm going to an alcohol therapist too. She gives me insight into why I drink, and reasons why I drink, and why I shouldn't drink anymore. And I told her that basically I want a healthy relationship with alcohol, if that's possible. I want to be able to drink sociably like everyone else. And she's led me to believe that I can't. I can no longer drink like everyone else. I don't care. And it's not that I don't care. I really do care, but I can't care.
我也在看酒精治疗师。她让我洞察了我为什么喝酒，为什么喝酒的原因，以及为什么我不应该再喝。我告诉她，基本上我想要和酒精建立一种健康的关系，如果可能的话。我想要像其他人一样能够社交性地喝酒。她让我相信我做不到。我不能再像其他人一样喝酒了。我不在乎。这并不是说我不在乎。我真的很在乎，但我不能在乎。
This really stunned me. Just a couple of months ago, he was talking to me about the possibility of enrolling in college. I think it's easy to assume that what you or I would want for Gregory is what he would want for himself: sobriety, a full-time job. But Gregory has had full-time jobs and doesn't want them anymore. And he doesn't want to be sober either. His new dream is to have it all. A roof over his head, like he has now. A job, but only part-time so he has lots of freedom to write. And booze.
这真的让我震惊。就在几个月前，他还在跟我谈论进入大学的可能性。我觉得很容易假设你或我希望格雷戈里的愿望是他自己想要的：清醒，一份全职工作。但格雷戈里已经有过了全职工作，他再也不想要了。他也不想清醒。他的新梦想是拥有一切。头顶上有个屋顶，就像他现在这样。有一份工作，但只是兼职，这样他就有大量的自由去写作。还有酒精。
And Daniel's dream is pretty much the same, though without such a serious commitment to drinking. And because Daniel and Gregory have each other, they make each other believe these dreams are possible. That's the great thing about their friendship. And maybe the worst thing.
丹尼尔的梦想也差不多，尽管没有对饮酒那么严肃的承诺。因为丹尼尔和格雷戈里拥有彼此，他们让对方相信这些梦想是可能的。这就是他们友谊的伟大之处。也许也是最糟糕之处。
Lu Olkowski in New York. Coming up, a kid is sent off on his bike with one simple instruction, just one thing that he has to do for his own good. But can he do it? The answer in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
卢·奥尔科夫斯基在纽约。接下来，一个孩子骑着自行车被送走，只有一个简单的指示，只有一件事，为了他好他必须做到的。但他能做到吗？答案将在稍后揭晓，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
[MUSIC - "SOWER OF SYSTEMS" BY LUNGFISH]
[音乐 - “播种者” By Lungfish]
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, social engineering. We have stories of people who are trying to re-engineer their own lives. Though actually, in this half of the show, we have parents trying to engineer the lives of their children. Basically, parenting is actually one long exercise in shaping your children's lives. In this next act, for instance, which we're calling "Take My Bike, Please," Dave Dickerson recalls a particular bit of parenting that went down in his boyhood home in Arizona. He was 12. His little brother had just gotten his first bike. Now Dave was getting one too.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周当然会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各类故事。今天的节目，“社会工程”。我们有关于人们试图重塑自己生活的故事。虽然事实上，在本节目的下半部分，我们有试图设计孩子生活的家长。基本上，育儿其实就是一场漫长的塑造孩子生活的练习。例如，在接下来的这一幕，我们称之为“请骑走我的自行车”，戴夫·迪克森回忆了他少年时代在家乡亚利桑那州发生的一件育儿轶事。他当时12岁。他弟弟刚得到了第一辆自行车。现在戴夫也要得到一辆了。
I was really excited. This was the most money we'd ever had spent on us. And I never had dreams of biking everywhere, like doing wheelies or all the things that junior high kids, I guess, are supposed to be thrilled about. It was just-- Tucson is a sprawling town. And there's a lot of walking, and a lot of bus riding. And it would just really save time. I was really excited about that. More free time to actually play video games, or whatever it is that I wanted to do, rather than wasting all my time in transit. And at the same time, there was the implied responsibility, like you'd better not mess this up.
我真的很兴奋。这是我们有史以来被花费最多的一次。我从来没有过骑车去任何地方的梦想，比如做翘头动作或者是初中生们应该对此感到激动的那些事情。这只是——图森是一个广阔的城镇。需要步行很多路，乘坐公交车。这真的会节省时间。我对此真的很兴奋。有更多的空闲时间去玩视频游戏，或者任何我想做的事情，而不是把时间浪费在路上。同时，有一种隐含的责任感，比如你最好别把这事搞砸了。
Dad said, hop in the car. Me and my brother got in and went to this used bike store with both my parents. So it was sort of a family outing. And I got the bike. It was this nice green bike. Dad said, so do you want to put this in the back of the car and drive home? Or do you want to ride it home? And I said, oh, I want to ride it home. And he said, OK, but don't stop anywhere because we don't have a lock for this thing. And I said, OK, yeah, no problem. And I drove off while Dad was still paying. And Dana went with me, and he was walking along beside me.
爸爸说，上车。我和我弟弟上了车，和父母一起去了这家二手自行车商店。这算是一次家庭郊游。我得到了自行车。这是一辆漂亮的绿色自行车。爸爸说，你想把这个放在车后座带回家吗？还是你想骑它回家？我说，哦，我想骑它回家。他说，可以，但别停在任何地方，因为我们没有锁。我说，好的，没问题。爸爸还在付钱时我就骑走了。达纳跟着我，走在我旁边。
And we got maybe a block, two blocks, whatever, when we passed this convenience store that we'd gone to a lot of times and thought, oh my God, we have to play Asteroids , this is so cool. Because I'm kind of an adult now, and I can make decisions like this. This was sort of the way I pictured my life with this bike, where I would get my allowance and bike to the store and play this game, and so on. And I couldn't wait for that to happen. So on that basis, I went, OK, let the fun begin.
我们大概走了有一个街区，两个街区，无论多少，当我们经过那家我们去过很多次的便利店时，心想，哦天哪，我们必须玩《小行星》，这太酷了。因为我算是个大人了，我可以做出这样的决定。这就是我设想中骑这辆自行车的生活方式，我可以拿到零花钱，骑车去商店玩游戏等等。我迫不及待地想让那发生。所以基于此，我去了，好吧，让乐趣开始吧。
But we knew we weren't supposed to stop. We didn't have a lock for the bike, but we decided we'd just take turns looking. We'd do a two player game, and when I was playing, Dana would watch. And when Dana was playing, I would watch. So I leaned the bike up against the front of the store. But what actually happened, of course, is that it's really hard to have someone playing a game right next to you, and you have to go on the second they die, and not look at the game. And then of course, you have to go, oh, be careful with the-- oh look, shields. We stopped looking. We would glance up occasionally. And when we came out, the bike was gone.
但我们知道我们不该停下来。我们没有锁，但我们决定轮流看着。我们玩双人游戏，我在玩的时候，达纳就看着。他在玩的时候，我就看着。所以我把自行车靠在商店门前。但实际上发生的是，当然，有人在旁边玩游戏真的很难，你必须在他死的瞬间立刻接手，而且不能看游戏。然后当然，你不得不说，哦，小心那个——哦看，护盾。我们不再看了。我们偶尔会抬头看一眼。当我们出来时，自行车不见了。
And we looked at each other utterly horrified. I remember we cried. And then almost without a word, I remember we just walked home. We realized this is it. We've got to walk the same path we've walked before, but it's going to be in the dark. And I do remember thinking, we're never going to get allowance again. We had been entrusted with this great gift at great expense, and we had screwed it up before we had even gotten the bike home. The one time, the one time I stepped outside the lines, the worst calamity possible happened.
我们面面相觑，惊恐万分。我记得我们哭了。然后几乎没说一个字，我记得我们只是走回家。我们意识到这就是结局了。我们必须走我们之前走过的同一条路，但要在黑暗中。我确实记得自己在想，我们要永远失去零花钱了。我们被赋予了这份极其昂贵的伟大礼物，却在还没把自行车骑回家之前就搞砸了。我唯一一次，唯一一次跨越界限，最糟糕的灾难就发生了。
As we got into our actual neighborhood, about half an hour, 45 minutes later, I just had to sort of walk toward my doom, walk toward judgment. Oh, God. We waited outside the door for a little while, gathering the courage to go in. And I opened the door, and my dad was there.
当我们到达实际的街区时，大约半小时，45分钟后，我不得不走向我的末日，走向审判。哦，天哪。我们在门外等了一会儿，积攒勇气进去。我打开门，爸爸在那。
So when you came in, and before you could really say much, I just said, the bike is in the back. I brought it home.
所以当你进来时，在你没能说太多之前，我只是说，自行车在后面。我把它带回家了。
Right.
对。
You had gone inside a Circle K or something and left the bike sitting out. And I decided to then make the object lesson of stealing the bike, which I just told your mother to take the car home. And I went and grabbed the bike and ran off with it. And what's more, somebody saw me do that. And they stopped me and said, why are you stealing this bike? I saw you steal that bike, they said. And then I'm talking to this stranger trying to explain why I'm stealing a bike.
你走进Circle K或者别的地方，把自行车放在外面。我决定把偷自行车作为教学案例，我告诉你们母亲把车先开回家。我去抓住了自行车，骑着它跑了。而且更重要的是，有人看到我那么做了。他们拦住我说，你为什么偷这辆自行车？我看到你偷了那辆自行车，他们说。然后我正在和一个陌生人解释我为什么要偷一辆自行车。
So you were riding my bike home?
所以你是骑着我的自行车回家？
Right. I just rode your bike home.
对。我只是骑着你的自行车回家。
Oh my God.
哦我的天。
And this guy stopped me. And then I had to explain to him, and he didn't really buy my story.
那个家伙拦住了我。然后我不得不向他解释，他并不太相信我的故事。
That's funny.
那很有趣。
Normally nobody pays any attention to somebody stealing a bike, right?
通常没人会注意有人偷自行车，对吧？
Right.
对。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was always bothered about that. I thought I had overdone things.
我一直对那事感到困扰。我想我做得太过火了。
Why? In what way?
为什么？以什么方式？
The issue for me was you had to come out of this store and discover the bike that you'd gotten an hour before is now gone and that you had to walk home for an hour, a mile and a half. And the regret then is just that this took away the pleasure of getting a new possession. It just sucks all the joy out of what should have been a really fun, exciting, new thing. And it just puts a black cloud over it.
对我来说的问题是你不得不走出商店，发现你一小时前刚得到的自行车现在没了，你不得不走一小时，一英里半的路回家。那种后悔就是，这剥夺了拥有新物品的乐趣。它抽干了原本应该是充满乐趣、令人激动的新事物的所有快乐。它在上面笼罩了一层乌云。
One of the things I learned from that was that I had been-- obviously, I was taking the bike for granted. It was that long walk home that made me realize-- I had time to think how much money I had squandered and lost by being foolish and gee, walking sucks. But I've always told people is that after that happened, I felt safe, safer than I had before. And that I realized that even if you screw up, sometimes you get a chance to-- that it's not over. You get second chances in life, even when you can't possibly imagine how they could happen.
从中我学到的一件事是——显然，我把自行车视为理所当然。正是那段长长的步行回家路让我意识到——我有时间思考通过犯傻我挥霍和损失了多少钱，走路真是烂透了。但我一直告诉人们的是，在那件事发生后，我感到安全，比以前更安全。我意识到，即使你搞砸了，有时你还有机会——事情并没有结束。生活中总有第二次机会，即使你无法想象它们会如何发生。
So I told my dad this on the phone, and he was surprised. It certainly wasn't what he was trying to teach me. In fact, it was the opposite of what he was trying to teach me. He was trying to demonstrate the world isn't safe. And what I learned was yes, it is. Or really I learned both things. Be careful, and sometimes you do get a second chance.
所以我把这事告诉了我父亲，他很惊讶。这当然不是他试图教我的。事实上，这和他试图教我的正好相反。他试图证明世界是不安全的。而我学到的是，是的，它是安全的。或者我真的学到了两件事。小心点，有时你确实会得到第二次机会。
Knowing what you know now, do you think it worked?
既然你知道现在的情况，你觉得那奏效了吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
So are you more OK with what you did?
所以你对你做的事感到更加释怀了吗？
Yeah, I'm feeling-- just as you felt safer, I'm feeling the same kind of grace, you see, towards me.
是的，我觉得——就像你感到更加安全一样，我也对你怀有同样的恩典。
Of course. You could also do what you think is a screw-up, and you get another chance, a different--
当然。你也可以做你认为搞砸的事，然后你得到另一次机会，不同的——
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
Aw, I love you Dad.
噢，我爱你，爸爸。
OK, I appreciate it.
好的，我很感激。
Dave Dickerson.
戴夫·迪克森。
Act Three, "Educated Guess." Amy Silverman is like most parents. She wants whatever's best for her kids. Except in her daughter Sophie's case, sometimes it is really hard to figure out what is best. Here's Amy.
第三幕，“受过教育的猜测”。艾米·西尔弗曼像大多数父母一样。她想把最好的给孩子。除了在女儿苏菲的案例中，有时确实很难弄清楚什么是最好的。这是艾米。
When Sophie was born, the nurses on the maternity ward all remarked on how mild her features were, that she barely looked like she had Down Syndrome. It means she'll be really high functioning, one of them said. And so for a long time, I held out secret hope that Sophie would be some kind of Down Syndrome genius. How sweet, I thought, when Sophie showed a particular interest in the kiddy doctor's kit someone gave her as a gift. OK, so not a surgeon, but maybe something else in the medical profession?
苏菲出生时，产科病房的护士们都评价说她的外貌很柔和，看起来几乎不像有唐氏综合症。其中一个说，这意味着她的功能水平会很高。所以很长一段时间里，我怀着一个秘密的希望，苏菲会是某种唐氏综合症天才。当苏菲对别人送给她作为礼物的一套儿童医生工具产生浓厚兴趣时，我想，多可爱。好吧，不是外科医生，但也许是医疗行业的其他职位？
My dream of Sophie being an over-achiever persisted, even as I signed her up for all the therapies I could find and wrote Down Syndrome and mentally retarded on countless school, medical, and insurance forms. Even so, I was unprepared for the following scene. In early February, I perched my butt on a tiny, navy blue plastic chair in Sophie's preschool classroom and faced her team, Team Sophie: the preschool teacher, speech pathologist, occupational therapist, physical therapist, principal, and school psychologist.
苏菲会出类拔萃的梦想一直持续着，即使我为她报了所有能找到的治疗课程，并在无数的学校、医疗和保险表格上填写“唐氏综合症”和“弱智”。即便如此，我还是对接下来的一幕没有准备。二月初，我蹲在苏菲学前班教室里一把海军蓝塑料小椅子上，面对她的团队，“苏菲团队”：学前班老师、言语病理学家、职业治疗师、物理治疗师、校长和学校心理学家。
The shrink was the first to talk. We've called you here today to ask you to sign some paperwork, so we can test Sophie. We don't think she qualifies as mentally retarded. You don't think she what? We don't think Sophie qualifies as mentally retarded, the psychologist repeated. We want to test her to find out. He shuffled a pile of paperwork. Immediately, I knew this had to do with money. Almost all of Sophie's services are paid for by the government. These days, that means two hours a week with a physical therapist, one each with speech, occupational, and music specialists, and more at school. I asked a question I knew the answer to, and what if she doesn't qualify anymore as mentally retarded? Then, he said, she'll lose her early intervention services. But why? Why wouldn't Sophie be retarded? He answered, early intervention services boosted her IQ.
心理医生首先发言。“我们今天叫你来是想请你签署一些文书，以便我们可以测试苏菲。我们认为她不符合弱智的资格。”“你不认为她什么？”“我们不认为苏菲符合弱智的资格，”心理学家重复道。“我们想测试她以找出答案。”他整理了一堆文书。我立刻知道这与钱有关。苏菲几乎所有的服务都由政府支付。这些日子意味着每周两小时的物理治疗，语言、职业和音乐专家各一小时，以及学校里更多的服务。我问了一个我知道答案的问题，“如果她不再符合弱智的标准怎么办？”他说，“那她将失去早期干预服务。”“但为什么？为什么苏菲不会被归类为弱智？”他回答说，“早期干预服务提升了她的智商。”
So here I was, sitting in front of Sophie's team of early intervention specialists while they were saying to me, we intervened in your retarded child's life so early and so well that she may no longer be retarded. And as a result, we may stop helping her. The whole thing was absurd.
所以我就坐在这里，在苏菲的早期干预专家团队面前，他们对我说，“我们如此早且出色地干预了你患有弱智的孩子的生活，以至于她可能不再是弱智了。因此，我们可能会停止帮助她。”整件事太荒谬了。
But I couldn't get the questions out of my head. What if Sophie somehow really isn't mentally retarded? What if? I started to worry. Maybe I'm not pushing her hard enough. Are my expectations too low? What if I'm underestimating my own kid? Could she have a much different and better life if I acted like there wasn't anything wrong with her, if I treated her like her sister?
但我脑子里挥之不去的问题是。如果苏菲真的不是弱智怎么办？如果？我开始担心。也许我没有足够地推动她。我的期望是否太低？如果我低估了自己的孩子怎么办？如果我表现得好像她没有任何问题，如果我像对待她姐姐那样对待她，她是否会拥有一个完全不同且更好的生活？
After a few weeks, Sophie's teacher emailed me to say the test results were in. Could we meet again? I emailed back, yes, I could meet. I couldn't wait, I had to ask. She still qualifies as mentally retarded, doesn't she, I wrote. I know you can't say. That's just my prediction. Services aside, of course, that will still make me a little sad. This whole thing has been a little like Flowers for Algernon . Did you ever read that story in school? Yes, she'd read the story. It made her really sad. And no, she told me, Sophie does not qualify as retarded. We scheduled the meeting, and the teacher sent home the test results.
几周后，苏菲的老师给我发电子邮件说测试结果出来了。我们可以再见面吗？我回信说，是的，我可以见面。我迫不及待了，我必须问。我写道，“她仍然符合弱智的资格，不是吗？我知道你不能说。这只是我的预测。暂且不论服务，当然，那仍然会让我有点难过。”整件事有点像《献给阿尔吉侬的花束》。你在学校读过那个故事吗？是的，她读过那个故事。这让她非常难过。不，她告诉我，苏菲不符合弱智的标准。我们安排了会议，老师把测试结果寄回了家。
Sophie's IQ is 83. The cutoff for mentally retarded is 70. Sophie, the test said, was able to correctly identify the color of her shoes, pink, and her pants, black. When asked her age, she said four, almost five. The test said a lot more and concluded she had below average intelligence. That startled me. I was so used to seeing the word retarded, it had lost meaning. But how dare someone say my daughter was below average. Retarded you can't do anything about. It's genetics. But below average? Below average is like she's not trying. Or I'm not trying.
苏菲的智商是83。弱智的截断分是70。测试说，苏菲能够正确识别她鞋子的颜色，粉色，以及她裤子的颜色，黑色。当被问及年龄时，她说四岁，快五岁了。测试说了更多内容，并得出结论她有低于平均水平的智力。这让我大吃一惊。我太习惯看到“弱智”这个词，它已经失去了意义。但谁敢说我的女儿低于平均水平。弱智你是无能为力的。这是基因。但低于平均水平？低于平均水平好像是她没努力。或者我没努力。
I sat at the table facing Team Sophie and looked at the psychologist. Instead, the principal spoke first. We all know what will happen if Sophie isn't labeled as mentally retarded, she said. She'll lose her services, services we all believe got her where she is today. Then she floored me. And so you have a decision to make, she said. You tell us what to do. You can label Sophie as mildly mentally retarded, and she can keep her services. Otherwise, she'll lose them. You have to decide today.
我坐在桌前，面对苏菲团队，看着心理学家。相反，校长首先发言。“我们都知道如果苏菲没有被标记为弱智会发生什么，”她说。“她将失去服务，我们都认为正是这些服务造就了她今天的成就。”然后她的话让我震惊。“所以你有一个决定要做，”她说。“你告诉我们该怎么做。你可以把苏菲标记为轻度弱智，这样她就能保留服务。否则，她会失去它们。你今天必须决定。”
My jaw dropped. Then I clenched it, pushing back the tears. It's got to be one of the most bizarre moments in a parent's life, being offered the chance to insist, my kid is too retarded. I thought of a little girl I know who's one grade ahead of Sophie. Like Sophie, she's got Down Syndrome, and she's smart. She didn't test as mentally retarded either. That mom didn't hesitate. She was happy to lose the mentally retarded label. Will that little girl have a better life with no label and way fewer services? Would Sophie?
我的下巴掉下来了。然后我紧咬牙关，强忍泪水。这一定是父母生活中最怪异的时刻之一，被提供了一个机会坚持“我的孩子太弱智了”。我想起我认识的一个小女孩，比苏菲高一个年级。像苏菲一样，她患有唐氏综合症，而且很聪明。她也没被测试为弱智。那个母亲没有犹豫。她很高兴失去“弱智”的标签。那个小女孩没有标签且服务少得多会过得更好吗？苏菲会吗？
This discussion was futile, and I knew it. For this moment in time, yes, Sophie is smart. She knows her ABCs. She can count to 20. She can even count to 10 in Spanish. But that's kindergarten stuff. Her vocabulary is good, but the low muscle tone associated with Down Syndrome makes her almost impossible to understand. And the occupational therapist isn't sure she'll ever be able to write. She hopes someday Sophie will be able to sign her name. In another year or two, I know she'll fall behind. The mild facial features she was born with will become more pronounced. She'll look more and more like what she is, a person with Down Syndrome. And whatever we decide today about whether or not to label her as mentally retarded, it won't change any of that.
这次讨论是徒劳的，我知道。在当下，是的，苏菲很聪明。她知道字母表。她能数到20。她甚至能用西班牙语数到10。但那是幼儿园水平的东西。她的词汇量不错，但与唐氏综合症相关的低肌肉张力使她几乎让人无法听懂。职业治疗师不确定她是否能写字。她希望有一天苏菲能签自己的名字。再过一两年，我知道她会落后。她出生时轻微的面部特征会变得更加明显。她看起来越来越像她本来的样子，一个患有唐氏综合症的人。无论我们今天决定是否标记她为弱智，都无法改变任何事情。
I signed the paperwork. The principal was nice enough to write on the forms that the team, including the mother, agonized over the decision. The psychologist left the room and edited the test results. The numbers stayed the same, but he added a part about how it was believed the results were inflated due to early intervention services. I bit my lip, wishing he could write something else.
我签署了文书。校长还算友善，在表格上写道包括母亲在内的团队对这一决定感到苦恼。心理学家离开了房间并编辑了测试结果。数字保持不变，但他增加了一部分，说明人们认为由于早期干预服务，结果被夸大了。我咬了咬嘴唇，希望他能写点别的。
My husband, Ray, had a different reaction. Well, he said, that was a no-brainer. Sophie is retarded. I don't know, I said tentatively. I think she's pretty smart. You know how I know Sophie's retarded, he asked. Because when you play a memory game with her, she gets as excited about the last match when there are only two cards left as she does at the first. It's true.
我的丈夫雷有不同的反应。“嗯，”他说，“那是不言而喻的。苏菲是弱智。”“我不知道，”我试探性地说。“我觉得她很聪明。”“你知道我怎么知道苏菲是弱智吗？”他问。“因为当你和她玩记忆游戏时，当只剩下两张牌时，她对最后一对配对的兴奋程度和第一张牌一样。”这是真的。
Last month, my mom took the girls and me to see the live Sesame Street show downtown. When the lights went down and the characters came on stage, Sophie was beside herself, squealing, shouting, about as excited as a human being can get. It was more fun to watch than Elmo. My mom, Annabelle, and I all grinned at each other. And then suddenly, out of nowhere, it hit me. I'll probably be taking Sophie to see Elmo when she's 20, and she'll be just as excited as she is today. I sat back, a little winded.
上个月，我妈带我和孩子们去看了市中心的芝麻街现场演出。当灯光暗下来，角色们出现在舞台上时，苏菲欣喜若狂，尖叫，欢呼，像人所能达到的最兴奋的状态。看她比看艾尔蒙更有趣。我妈、安娜贝尔和我相视一笑。然后突然，毫无预兆地，我意识到了。我可能在苏菲20岁时还会带她去看艾尔蒙，而她会像今天一样兴奋。我向后靠在椅子上，有点喘不过气来。
I swear I'm not making this next part up. A moment later, I looked up. And there, in the dim light, I saw the silhouette of a short, squat, adult person. The features were unmistakable, the tiny nose, the flat head, the bent posture. The person disappeared down a row and into the crowd, but not before he or she had confirmed the future.
我发誓下一部分我不是编的。片刻之后，我抬起头。在那里，昏暗的灯光下，我看到了一个矮小、敦实成年人的剪影。特征是明确无误的，小鼻子，平头，弯曲的姿势。那个人消失在走道里并进入人群，但在确认未来之前。
Amy Silverman. She's the managing editor at the weekly paper Phoenix New Times in Arizona.
艾米·西尔弗曼。她是亚利桑那州周报《凤凰城新时报》的主编。
Our show today was produced by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Emily Youssef. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Special thanks today to Alex Kotlowitz, Julie Miller, Katie Rolnick, and Andrea Silenzi.
我们今天的节目是由罗宾·塞米恩和我制作的，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安·马修维茨运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自赛斯·林德和艾米丽·优素福。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。特别感谢亚历克斯·科特洛维茨、朱莉·米勒、凯蒂·罗尼克和安德里亚·西伦齐。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where this week we are starting a contest where you design our next t-shirt. Details at thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org，本周我们正在举办一场比赛，设计我们的下一件T恤。详情请访问thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says it was just one thing that he did not know was inevitably going to be part of running any big public radio station.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他说这只是他不知道会成为运营任何大型公共广播电台必然组成部分的一件事。
Celibacy. That was the biggest thing. I didn't think about it.
“禁欲。那是最大的一件事。我完全没想过。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。